now I'd like to show you a tweet from
Greta thunberg who is a true wizard uh
Greta of course the climate I almost I
would had a funny one there but I didn't
I'm not saying
it damn she's a climate chick uh here
she is a tweet from her week 270 today
we strike in solidarity with Palestine
and Gaza the world needs to speak up and
call for an immediate ceasefire Justice
and freedom for Palestinians and
civilian
affected just just leave it up for a
second first look how happy these chicks
are all these people end up endlessly
miserable Greta thumber how old is she
she's like 15 she looks like she's 72
right like they all end up with that
frumpled brow and just miserable there
just there's just misery and hate there
this Jew stands with Palestine yeah go
go to Gaza lady okay uh
anyway the climate activists you might
go well wait a minute what do the
climate activists have to do with Gaza
also she say she say she says stands
with Gaza and Palestine saying you stand
for Palestine or what's going on between
Palestine and Israel makes no sense it
would be like saying what's going on in
Israel versus Israel because as you know
there was never was a state of Palestine
right okay fine I accept that they're
all just kind of ridiculous but you look
at these young people and you go well
why are young people rampaging through
these colleges why are they out on the
street why are they screaming there's a
genocide when if you look we're going to
show you a graph in a second the
population of Gaza is exploding it's
going up this way right right um why are
they so confused about all of these
issues well it's because of that
education thing that Bill Maher was
referencing so now I want to show you
this video this is a spectacular video
that I saw over the weekend it's by a
guy by the name of ysf Hadid he is in
isra he's in Israel Arab so he lives in
Israel he's Arab not Jewish full
equality he was a member of the IDF the
Israel Defense Forces uh and he is the
CEO of a of a nonprofit called together
vouch for each other which is an
organization that's devoted to Bringing
Arabs and Jews together in Israel this
is all wrong I shouldn't be up
here I should be back in
school how dare you you have stolen my
dreams my childhood with your empty
words and yet I'm one of the lucky ones
people are suffering people are dying
how dare you continue to look away you
say you hear us and that you understand
the urgency if you really understood the
situation and still kept on failing to
act then you would be evil and that I
refuse to believe how dare you pretend
that this can be sold with just business
as usual you are failing us we will not
let you get away with this right here
right now is where we draw the
line the world is waking
up and change is coming with whether you
like it or not thank
[Applause]
you so as you can see very clever what
he did right there like when you take
her words and then you apply them to
this things are a little bit
different